to the sacred abortion experience  that's a whole lot of thought and prayer  and liturgy and worship for a  meaningless clump of cells don't you  think so she's saying you know put the  dead baby into this little jar on the  altar with some incense with the  abortion drugs and you're going to  worship at this sacred altar people are  looking at this and they're saying oh my  gosh this is so this is the craziest  thing ever although can you believe this  yes i can believe it this is the norm in  human history it is a human sacrifice an  actual visible  undeniable human sacrifice  and that is the norm  not killing babies is the exception in  human history  in christian civilization we say no  human sacrifice no killing our babies no  we try to tamp down eugenics which  is also plays a huge role in abortion  and also has been practiced all around  the world since the dawn of time